de la réalité à la fiction place au
cinéma dans les livraisons de la semaine
tueurs nés le dernier film de oliver
stone la dernière bombe serait on tenté
de dire après platoon et la guerre du
vietnam après jfk sur l'assassinât du
président kennedy
oliver stone interroge cette fois
l'amérique d'aujourd'hui à travers le
voyage sanglant d'un couple de tueurs en
série il dénonce la violence qui fascine
et qui envahit les écrans de télévision
pascal deschamps et pascal pons le
rencontrer
mais
bien sûr il ya mickey et mallory 52
meurtres à leur tableau de chasse toute
ressemblance avec des personnages
existants ou ayant existé n'est bien sûr
pas une coïncidence car il ya tous les
autres criminels petits ou grands qui
ont défrayé la chronique de la cavale de
jean sonne suivis en direct par des
centaines de millions de téléspectateurs
à la fère bobbitt en passant par la fac
de la secte de watsco et si oliver stone
a choisi de mettre ces images au
générique ce n'est pas un hasard film
qui a commencé comme une bande dessinée
c'était absurde c'était plus grand que
la vie ça tire bien mais corps pendant
qu'on faisait le film voilà tous ces
choses arrivent et après l'autre une
femme à couper le fil de son mari avait
été célébré l'an publique monsieur
sommes seuls une femme pâtissent
patineuse pouces une autre patineuse et
m'étais mis nos méthodes dollars sont
gagnés les pleurs de nancy kerrigan en
fait de sa rivale une star les procès
télévisé bat des records d'audience
celui de mickey et mallory n'échappe pas
à la règle c'est de tout cela que leur
cavale sanglante se veut le symbole
symbole d'un système où le spectacle
remplace l'information je pense aux fins
quand cette infime morale parce que ça
ça demande la question pourquoi qu'est
ce que c'est notre relation à la
violence que ce que c'est notre l'un sur
la télévision l'émission consacrée à nyc
et mallory est l'une de celles qui a le
plus de succès sur john wayne gacy oui
j'ai fait le meilleur score chez vous
voulez mais en français et l'autre
espèce d'enfoiré ted bundy
c'est dingue non non non vous avez un
milieu artistique ou to be meilleur
janot vient la voir manson
alors je vais mètres de là les meurtres
de ces gens dans un contexte du siècle
et je montre montrer les agressions
universel dans tout le monde tout le
monde est dans un sens un tueur né car
comme dans tous ses films
oliver stone ne cache pas ses intentions
politiques en mettant en scène sa propre
violence la société américaine fait
l'économie d'un débat sur ces causes la
répression n'est pas une solution nous
dit il presque dans le désert alors que
les exécutions capitales se multiplient
aux etats-unis sans qu'une seule voix
s'élèvent
[Musique]